BUCKET OF CHICKEN MANURE IN THE
DIRECTION OF THE BUILDING.
HE WAS PROMPTLY ARRESTED.
>> Bret: DOUG McKELWAY IN
LEXINGTON VIRGINIA.
THANKS.
THE PRESIDENT IS ANOINTING
MAXINE WATERS AS THE FACE OF THE
DEMOCRATS AND MANY OF HER
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ARE
CRITICAL OF HER COMMENTS AS
WELL.
AND YET SEVERAL PROMINENT
LIBERAL COMMENTATORS BELIEVE
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
HARASSING POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
TONIGHT FOX NEWS MEDIA AND HOST
OF FOX NEWS MEDIA BUZZ
HOWARD KURTZ PUT THIS SITUATION
VIRGINIA RESTAURANT HAD REFUSED
TO SERVE SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS,
SOME PUNDITS, THOSE WHO DETEST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, STARTED
CHEERING.
THE PRESS SECRETARY THEY SAID
DESERVES THE RUDE TREATMENT.
>> YOU MAKE CHOICES IN LIFE AND
THERE IS A COST TO BEING AN
ACCOMPLICE TO THIS CRUEL,
DECEITFUL ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE DEFINING FEATURE OF A
FREE SOCIETY IS THAT YOU CAN
TELL ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
>> MSNBC CONTRIBUTOR JENNIFER
RUBIN SAYS TRUMP OFFICIALS COULD
BE, SOCIAL PROPRIETORS OF SORTS.
MOST CONSERVATIVES AREN'T
DENOUNCED THE END ACCIDENT AND
PROTESTS CONFRONTING OUR TRUMP
AIDS ESPECIALLY AFTER DEMOCRATIC
HARASSMENT.
>> SHOUTING EACH OTHER DOWN,
KICKING OUR POLITICAL ENEMIES
OUT OF RESTAURANTS, HECKLING
THEM IN PUBLIC MAY FEEL GOOD IN
THE MOMENT, BUT IT ISN'T A
SOLUTION.
>> THREATENING WOMEN AND
CHILDREN, WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT?
>> DAVID AXELROD GROUP DRC
>> DAVID AXELROD GROUP DRI
>> DAVID AXELROD GROUP DRM
FROM DEMOCRATS FOR TAKING
SANDERS SIDE.
WRITING KIND OF AMAZED AND
APPALLED BY THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
IN THE LEFT TO ASK APPLAUDED THE
RESTAURANT.
TRUMP OPPONENTS ARE USING THE
PRESIDENT'S PREVIOUS POLICY OF
FAMILY SEPARATION AT THE BORDER
TO JUSTIFY THEIR IN-YOUR-FACE
TACTIC.
THESE CLIPS FROM MSNBC'S MORNING
JOE.
>> IF YOU SEE SOMEBODY GETTING
READY TO THROW TOMATO, KNOCK THE
I WOULD LIKE TO PUNCH HIM IN THE
FACE, SERIOUSLY.
>> OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS HAD BEEN ARRESTED IN
SIMILAR FASHION.
IT'S NOT HARD TO IMAGINE BOTH
MAGNIFIED BY A POLARIZED MEDIA
ENVIRONMENT AND SOCIAL MEDIA.